So we already talked about the general
version of the distributive property is
that if you have some variable, or number,
or expression, or really anything in the
slot where a is and you want to multiply
that by some set of terms that are added
together Inside parentheses. They could
also, of course, be subtracted. Then the
factor that you want to multiply
everything by distributes its
multiplication to each term that's inside
the parentheses. So we end up with a * b,
or ab over here, + a * c, ac over here.
Now, we already saw how we use the
distributive property when we want to
subtract polynomials from one another. But
in those situations, we let a = -1, and
clearly, a could equal many other things
besides -1. So, let's try something out,
where a is a different number.